[Music]
jose is with us
in detroit hey jose what's up
hello joe's joe's hello yeah
oh there he is there he is we found the
phone good what's up man
sorry about that it was on mute no
troubles how can we help
um so i'm looking to go back to grad
school and i'm kind of curious as to
whether i should be taking out the
student loans to do so
well jos do you listen to the show very
much
not very much my brother is the one that
actually put me on to the show recently
he tricked you he did well i'm glad
you're here
brother said step up on this trap
and we're going to pull the rug out call
it brother
your brother you owe your brother a
punch in the nose you do he
he said call this guy that hates debt
and ask him if you should take out debt
he's
he's got some popcorn listen to this
call right now jose listen
no we don't want you to take out student
loans not for
a master's degree not for any degree we
want you to save up and pay cash what do
you want to do
what do you want to get your degree in
cyber security okay what are you doing
now
uh so i actually was working in i.t i
actually recently quit my job
uh but so right now i'm not doing
anything but i
was working in it for a state agency
okay so why do you need a master's in
cyber security to work in cyber security
we got cyber security people working
here
none of them have even a four year
degree in it
um i don't know if you necessarily need
one so i didn't go to school
because there are lots of people with
cybersecurity degrees who have made it
happen
um i didn't go to school for any of this
all this kind of just like fell in my
lap and i kind of worked it out
through work as i was doing it um and
i want to i want to be really really
good at what i do
and so i there's lots of knowledge that
i don't have in my years there have been
things that have come up just because i
didn't have that
but i learned from google then there are
things that'll
come up missing so i'm just kind of
looking to go to school
for them to actually teach me the things
that i need to know and then and then go
into the field
that is very wise you're very smart
in what you have described um as a
person who has a
thousand people working for me 440 of
them are technology people
many of them in cyber security our cyber
security guys were at work last night as
a matter of fact had an issue
and um so uh in other words i'm the
employer
that you want to hire you later in a
sense you follow me
so coming from that perspective i'm am
qualified to tell you
i would not require that you have a
master's degree as a matter of fact i'm
pretty sure
getting a master's degree in information
technology will not
teach you what you're trying to get
instead
you are already on the right track and
in practical experience is what i'd be
looking for number one
number two i would want you to pick up
some of the trade
certificates certification programs like
microsoft search and some of those
others
and there's plenty of really good
one-off training
in cyber security that would actually
give you the information that you are
looking for
the knowledge that you are looking for
to be able to do the thing that you're
wanting to do
versus a master's degree is very
academic
and uh honestly by the time you finish
it the stuff you learned will probably
be obsolete
it's going to be dated that's right jose
i'm curious why did you quit your job
because i wanted to go to school
um so i was kind of feeling stuck at
work for a little bit
and uh decided that i wanted to make the
career change
okay um but wasn't quite sure how to get
into it
uh so then school looked like to be a
good option and i actually got into
one of the best cyber security schools
in the country and um i want to get into
what's it called so i want to be the
carnegie mellon
what's it cost uh carnegie mellon what
does it cost
oh what does it cost sorry at least it
was default uh hundred thousand dollars
okay i would not spend that
okay i really wouldn't i mean you can do
what you want to do you you
but you and you obviously called some
people you hardly know who we are and
we're
we're screwing with your dream so it's
hard for you to hear all this but i'm
just telling you
as as the employer that i mean with a
thousand person team here
400 tech people on the team i couldn't
give a rip
less if you went to carnegie mellon or
not just let me tell you here's what
here's what i would do
instead if i were you and it's going to
still move you in the direction you want
to go
i would find a company that you want to
do cyber security for
i would go take a pay cut yep and do
anything for them
and study under them and learn how to do
the things you don't know how to do
while on the job while getting paid
which is still going to pay you more
than you're making now which is nothing
better than that they will also pay
tuition and you're not in a hundred
thousand dollars
not to the carnegie mellon they'll just
pay you tuition to go get the search
that'll give you the knowledge that you
need to do the job you're looking to go
do
so we just saved you a hundred thousand
dollars in debt and you have an income
while learning how to do the things you
want to do you just signed up for
harvard
is what you signed up for and the
question is
is there an roi when you pay full price
for harvard
and the answer is in such a small
percentage of jobs will you make a
return on investment on this
that it is not a good investment if you
were my son
i would advise you the exact way we are
advising you right now
and that's not the trash carnegie melon
it's to say
that in the field that you're in the
rate of change of information is
daily it's daily
while you're getting this degree some of
the languages
and code that you know right now will
become obsolete
while you're getting this degree the
processes
some of the companies that provide
security
apps and provide security software will
be out of business
while you're getting this degree it's
the rate of change
is blinding in the technology world
you have to be in a dead sprint to keep
up with it when it is your career but if
you
sideline yourself and go into crunchy
academic world
while you're doing this i'm i mean and
it's not to say that carnegie mellon
isn't cutting edge i suspect they are
you some of you people are gonna
troll me on this just troll your butt
away i'm the one that'll be hiring you
the here's the thing josh you know who
people want to hire
people they know that they've seen do
the job on the job not someone that has
a certificate with a certain brand on it
someone they've worked with someone they
trust they've watched them go be that
person if you had a hundred thousand
cash in the bank i tell you not to do it
if you're borrowing money i'm gonna yell
at you for doing it
don't do it son now you go do what you
want to do
and you can call us later and we'll
still love you and we'll still help you
even if you do stupid stuff this is the
ramsay show